- Nous sommes sur la ligne
de front ukrainienne,
face à Donetsk, aux mains des
séparatistes russes depuis 2014.
Ce qu'il voit avec ses jumelles,
nous ne pouvons pas le montrer.
C'est la pointe sud de
la tenaille russe pour encercler
les défenseurs uenenenens
du Donbass. Cette ligne n'a
pratiquement pas bougé depuis,
et les soldats du bataillon
Samate attendent la grande
offensive annoncée
de pied ferme.
Ivanovitch, c'est son surnom,
dit qu'ils se font tirer dessus
fréquemment, surtout la nuit,
comme sur les villages alentour,
et ils répliquent.
"Bien sûr, on doit répondre,
il faut bienfefefefendre!"
De nouvelles armes modernes
viennent d'arriver, cadeau de
l'Allemagne. L'Ukraine reconnaît
maintenant quiuiuiui en fournit
assez.
Celle-là vient de Suède,
très précise pour les tanks
et d'un mode d'emploi facile.
L'idée, c'est que les chars
russes finissent comme celui-ci,
souvenir de 2014, ce qui
se produit fréquemment.
Le bataillon est divisé ainsi :
il y a le quartier général,
puis, plus en avant, une série
de trois compagnies, elles-mêmes
divisées vers l'avant
en trois positions.
La position est pourvue
trtrtrtrtrailleuse.
Andrei dit qu'elle ne sert que
pour lesnsnsnsnsns sérieuses.
Ensemble, les positions peuvent
effectuer des tirs croisés.
En attendant la grande
offensive, il y a
cacacacacarmou,
les Russes ont été repoussés;
pas plus tard qu'hier,
dit Andrei.
Il est ici depuis plusieurs
mois - personne ne rentre
chez soi - et il est prêt
à rester encore longtemps,
jusqu'à la victoire.
Tout est relié par un réseau
de tranchées constamment
améliorées. Notre guide dans
les tranchées, c'est Irina.
Évidemment, l'armée ne veut pas
amener les journalistes dans des
endroits exposés, mais elle veut
leur montrer que ces soldats
sont professionnels,
bien équipés et surtout,
(tirs au loin)déterminés.
Plusieurs fois pendant
venus du côté russe.s de canons
Pour l'instant ici,
l'Ukraine est sur la défensive.
Mais comme l'armée russe
encaisse de lourdes pertes,
"un pour dix, dit Irina, parce
que nous sommes plus techniques
et rapides", le bataillon
s'attend à passer à l'offensive
un jour, mais il est prêt.
"Quand on va recevoirdrdrdrdrd,
nous sommes prêts."
Ce que le bataillon défend,
ce sont des villes comme
de Kharkiv au nord à Donetsk aua
sud. La gare de Kramatorsk a été
touchée par un missile russe qui
est tombé au milieu de la place
et dont les éclats ont fait
une cinquantaine de morts
et beaucoup de blessés.
Sur le stationnement, sur le
quai, on y a laissé des fleurs.
Les habitants sont partis ensse
fantôme; presque tout est fermé.
Ceux qui restent continuent
à vaquer à leurs occupations,
les transports en commun
fonctionnent.
Non loin, à Bakhmut, un missile
a détruit ce qui semble être une
usine, probablement un entrepôt
militaire. Là aussi, les gens
aussi ont fui la ville.
Mais pas ces chauffeurs de taxi.
Ils restent.
"On n'a pas d'argent
pour partir de toute façon."
Mais ont-ils peur?
Non, ils ont des sous-sols
bien aménagés.
Le seul commerce encore ouvert
ici, c'est la fleuriste.
Même si les gens sont partis,
elle vend s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s, il
reste des anniversaires à fêter.
Mais elle a peur.
Elle ne sait pas si
elle va rester ou partir.
Ces employés municipaux
continuent le travail
comme si de rien n'était.
Plus au nord, c'est Sloviansk
et là, la ligne de front
n'est pas loin.
(sirène d'alarme)plplplplplplpl,
la sirène hurle jour et nuit,
comme pour faire partir ceux qui
résistent, comme les pigeons.
À la limite de la ville,
on entend les canons russes...
... puis la réplique
ukrainienne.
(tirs au loin)
Le canon qui a tiré s'en va à
toute vitesse se placer ailleurs
avant d'avoir été détecté
et frappé.
Sloviansk également
est pratiquement déserte.
rarara,
la gare est fermée.
Comment évaluer les chances
de subir le sort de Marioupol
ou Irpin, ou bien d'être épargné
comme Kiev?
Sloviansk est la première ville
du nord du
les Russes doivent capturer
s'ils veulent faire la jonction
avec leurs troupes venues
du sud. Ils pourraient ainsidudt
tout en encerclant les forces
ukrainiennes qui y sont
retranchées depuis 2014.
Mais c'est loin d'être acquis,
car les Ukrainiens se croient
capables de les en empêcher
et de leur infliger une défaite
pour la deuxième fois.
Jean-Michel Leprince,
Radio-Canada, Sloviansk.